I reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we have read every Star Wars
book comic and watched every show this
isn't a reaction we're just gonna watch
a scene and then enjoy it and be like
glad we got a real watch that hi that
was the best joke I've ever made in my
entire life
so to watch the clones are ambushed on
the maiden Road clip a few days ago we
did a reaction when a new rock stars
videos talking about Star Wars new
timeline and basically going over a
timeline of the shows and the movies the
idea of the OTO and how it all unfolds
out in linear fashion we've seen the
movies and stuff we're gonna watch the
Mandalorian but we haven't actually seen
any of the shows and I'm planning on
actually after Rises Skywalker starting
up a linear order fashion starting with
whatever the first show was and it
wasn't Clone Wars there we go people
already clicked off anyway this is a top
reward tier video requests from a man
named Matthew Cronin and he said this is
a clip from one of the best episodes of
the Clone Wars season 4 episode 7 no
spoiler there's just great animation and
action directed by Stuart Lee just a
little anti scences watched the show
live I guess he's trying to get us to
react to the show we'll see we'll see
you say no spoilers yet it's such a
popular scene
this better be great love this so why
are we sticking to the original plan and
probing the city defenses first we can
do this let's take them yeah leave it to
hardcase to dive in headfirst the
generals new plan is record Red Hot
Chili Peppers maybe the general knows we
is doing it I know you think this is a
bad idea
well the death camp yeah who raised my
objection to general Krell's plan but he
didn't agree so this is it but what if
he's wrong then what this isn't the time
for a debate right now we have to stay
alert
I think it's really silent yeah that's
right
hey this is shot pretty cool
[Laughter]
Wow cool oh man this is her it's awesome
mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah I can see why you adults actually
watch this year how I stopped this if
this is like a super kitty I've never
seen a commercial it's just like
galaxy's edge
evil-minded clones
and it's the coolest gun in the world
damn it's like all-out battle
[Music]
is it over
yeah I guess so yeah that's pretty cool
yeah yeah that's pretty sweet
yeah I've always been under the
impression that it was just like Star
Wars for little kids
hey it's a kid accessible certainly but
maybe not maybe this is carrying on some
of the more sophisticated ideas of Star
well the way they edit and frame and the
type of tracking emotion shots that they
have here this is like a real tense
action scene yeah yeah cinematic this
isn't just some kids show yeah I always
thought that like it was made for kids
but if you want like more history or
more as a Star Wars fan it's best to
still watch it so that way you can cool
all that knowledge in history and such
then I was watching it's like oh this is
actually just a really cool I didn't I'm
sorry yeah you know I mean you have to
admit that I did well done see honesty
transparency once walked around looking
for a black bastard honesty transparency
always goes over always but I mean this
does look pretty neat and it makes me
think that Star Wars is a funny thing
because I'm not gonna necessarily say
it's for kids but I think that there is
something very kid accessible about the
original films most of us at this
generation and certainly of the next
generations have seen it as children or
or have memories of watching it as
children so I feel like something like
this has a ton of potential to be very
easy for a kid to get into but also be
very pleasing to the people sure spend
so much time being Star Wars fans are oh
and this just goes to support that yeah
because it seems like you'll get just as
much of the cool science-fiction action
you loved as a kid and as an adult now
now it just makes me curious about what
the storytelling is like you know John
I'm sure the storytelling is great look
when you stop watching all the current
anime shows that we're watching on
patreon oh yes like like which one and
all them well it might hero academia is
coming back but let's face yeah no one
cares no one cares great wanna watch us
three watch this show that has it coming
back
versus being refined that's right that's
the big deal yeah it's coming back
they've revived it it's safe it's a
clone of its own so what if we only
stopped watching every show but
Supernatural and ketchup funnel juice
and then catch it but all we should just
change the only Star Wars a Mandalorian
oh just watch them all like one Episode
watch Mandalorian and I will be one
together then you take the Clone Wars
and I'll take Clone Wars mmm you take
rebels and I'll take resistance well
what I was thinking was we watch each
one of them individually and then we re
watch them together yeah definitely to
see if our thoughts hold up if we have
the same yeah they're different opinions
yeah and notice the same details you
know where I'm going with this reaction
it highlights for all of them that's all
gonna have to change once the Boy Meets
World revival comes in and Feeny non Boy
Meets World Saved by the Bell
mr. Belding yeah
I'm sure this was a great contribution
to this close and now all we have is the
rest of the show surrounding this one
clip from season four episode 7 to get
it yeah I mean I don't know if we'll
react to this Matthew but I'm definitely
gonna at least start it up maybe I can
catch up fast enough to react to the
latest oh yeah probably the best one be
about 22 minutes or so an hour-long
solid per episode a hundred and seventy
hours of the Clone Wars you're at
minimum 55 minutes episodes HBO showers
always been kid-friendly that's quite
their home demon that's why Disney
Disney XD has Star Wars they're owned by
Disney even the hard gritty new
Mandalorian show is on Disney Plus where
they won't let it be that hard and great
yeah we'll see about that let's see all
right guys well do you think we should
pressure ourselves into catching up on
Star Wars the Clone Wars so we could
react to the latest season put your
comments down below especially if you're
not a patron
especially want your feedback
although hey I mean maybe that would be
great for figuring out what could bring
in more patrons as what do you want what
would bring you in that's not here now
Shawn hmm John we have vemula's time
patreon is dying YouTube is on the rise
that's right yeah this new platform
we've all together is a way for patrons
to compensate for the lack of what's
been going on over at patreon yeah now
people are doing YouTube mm-hmm so keep
that in mind what a free alternative um
Matthew hey buddy listen
kotas like what I've noticed about you
Matthew is that every request you have
given us has been solidly consistent
great man mm-hm and you have this habit
of going I'm gonna pledge the top
rewards here
now I'm um pledging or like I'm lowering
my pledge which is cool we're always
cool with people doing that but you've
done this like four months in a row so I
just find it kind of funny cuz it's such
a drastic difference between the lowest
routier and and the highest here
obviously your Lord Jesus I get it it's
difficult to afford but then at the
beginning of everybody maybe he just
wants to make absolutely sure by the end
of the month that he's got that balance
and positives I could learn a thing or
two from you about how to watch my
spending because now with the fact of
how YouTube has been a booming market I
am low did dad too much money going
around here too much I spent it all on
male strippers and male booze in a
mailing service surprisingly that's
trend I think sending all those letters
this and boxes and the packages and I
didn't really put anything in I just
wanted to spend the money